what's thought about stronger this is a
very powerful movie and I all joking
aside I thought your portrayal was
absolutely fantastic and this film puts
you in the position of this young man
who loses his legs in the bombing and
then suddenly he's a hero doesn't know
why he's a hero he's trying to keep a
relationship going everywhere he goes
people in Boston are trying to give him
a shot trying to get him to drink and
it's a incredibly intense experience I
thought you did an amazing job this
movie thank you I mean you said earlier
it was a movie about the bombing it's
not it's a movie about this
extraordinary human being going through
like all of us you know in many
different ways in our life or know
somebody who may be struggling who's
going through something that seems
impossible it seems like he'll never get
through it and he does yeah and to me
that's what the movies about it does
happen to be set in Boston which is an
extraordinary city and their spirit is
incredible you might know a little bit
about that I didn't get any of that
that's why I was asked to leave oh and
and and that's really what the story's
about is about how resilient we can be
in times where we think we can't go any
farther that we won't survive that we
can and I think you know it was an honor
to play him you know given everything
that's going on today with everything
going on in the country in the world you
know just hearing yesterday about Mexico
hearing about all the hurricanes hearing
about so many things in people's lives
being torn apart you know his story
makes me think and makes others think as
I have been around him that things could
get better and they will get better yes
yeah it's an amazing it's a great
testament to his spirit human spirit we
have a clip
we have a clip from stronger I've seen
the film but I don't know which clip
that you chose to to show us well one of
them one of the moments in the movie
where you know he's Jeff struggled with
all the attention that he was getting
and you know this you know he says he
was like he was sucker-punched and this
happened and a lot of people were
calling him a hero and he he didn't
really know how to do that or understand
what that meant while he was trying to
recalibrate everything in his life and
there's a scene where he went to Fenway
and he threw out the first pitch and
lots of people start coming up to him
and this is the scene where a guy comes
up to him and and you should see what he
says all right well we have no time
let's go
here's a clip from stronger you showed
the world that they can't and break us
no matter what the hell they do you know
it gave me a little hope made me feel a
little better nice horsey thank you for
that man that's all
my name is Larry Larry
I shake my hand yeah
[Music]
it's gonna be alright
okay right
[Music]
yeah one of the things I thought one of
the things I thought you captured so
beautifully and I could when we had Jeff
on the show last night we could tell
just talking to him that there are so
many people that want Fame want
attention and we have a culture that
where people were starved for that or
they believed that that's what they want
he gets all of this attention and
because he's really a pure soul he
doesn't really know what to do with it
and and you portray that so well
everyone's constantly wanting you to
saying you're a hero and you're you're
almost bent over with the weight of
being that yes it's it's a really
incredible story you know what's
incredible about the story beyond the
story of the movie is to see how far
Jeff's come in the past year since we
finished moving the filming it you know
to see that he has now that weight is
now something that holds him up and I
think he it's the reason why he's really
excited about the movie and why he
shared so much of his life with
everybody because I feel like he knows
that his story can tint touch people
just like it doesn't that that scene
with that guy you know there are videos
of Jeff when I was studying him and
trying to learn how to play him that you
would never believe just people lining
up like lining up for miles it feels
like Field of Dreams people just coming
up and saying this happened this
happened to me to my mother didn't my
father to my brother to my sister and my
cousin to my uncle to me and when I hear
your story it makes me feel like I can
get through it and he's extraordinary
you